um
i want to start right where we left off
which is in
filling atoms filling electrons
into atoms we've done a lot of work to
to know what it is that we're filling we
had to go
all the way to quantum to know
what orbitals are not just orbits
right and and we talked about the
the four quantum numbers right
and so now we're going to use those
and we're going to use the exclusion
principle from pauli
and a few other things and we're going
to fill electrons
into atoms so this is where we left off
on monday
there they are right remember um it you
know
as i said on monday if we only had bohr
what we would have is the left hand side
here n equals one
right we would have just n equals one
two three four five
but we wouldn't have uh any of this
variation of l
right uh like the the p electrons
uh the d electrons there that
differentiation
came in when we solved the equations of
quantum mechanics
right for an electron uh uh in
feeling the potential of the proton
now uh and then the other thing that
happens is
these things don't line up necessarily
exactly how you might
imagine because there are complicated
effects right so
so you know it's not it's not just a
naive
filling instead um instead there's
there's these effects like shielding
right so so
electrons all the way out here in an
atom they don't necessarily see all that
all the protons are shielded
uh and then to make matters even more
complicated
these orbitals can can wiggle
in with nodes right this is what we did
monday with nodes
all the way in so they can see some of
these orbitals have a little bit of them
that see the protons up close
right so we we we showed that with 2s
that's called orbital
penetration and that's why these things
split up they have the same
principal quantum number n is 2 but this
has a lower energy
than the 2p right okay because it's got
and now but how is the electron moving
within this orbital
no it's not that's a classical way of
thinking
right and it's so hard to stop thinking
that way i know we want to think that
way
but it's not an electron is being in its
orbital
because an orbital is a probability
distribution
right so the electron all we know from
the orbital
is that the electron has a probability
of being here sometimes in a probability
of being there
other times right that's what it tells
us so we know that in that 2s orbital
sometimes it's really really close to
those protons
right that was that orbital penetration
the peak that you saw
on monday all right so with all that
knowledge and just kind of getting us
back in the mood here
and our quantum numbers and our poly
exclusion
we're ready to fill and the way that
um we're gonna start
is the way that most uh
chemistry textbooks would would start
which is with a
very simple rule right
called the aufbau principle and aufbau
means so aufbau means
filling up in german
and and basically the the idea is that
you fill
you fill from
the lowest levels the lowest
those are also the ground state right
the ground state would be the
lowest right that's the lowest
um uh energy
lowest levels at ground state level
energy
uh and up okay
and you use what
is called the n plus l rule
the m plus cell rule means that the
ordering
the ordering
okay of the orbital energies
or betal
energies and let's get a little more
space here
okay the ordering of the orbital
energies
uh increases
with increasing
n plus l right and you fill from the
lowest energy
up so as my n plus l those are the you
know remember that
that's the shape right this is the the
sort of related to the distance from the
nucleus it's the principal quantum this
is related to the shape of the orbital
right l um and as that number increases
the energy that's how you feel oh but
there's the case where
uh it might be the same right so
we have to have another point here which
is
when two orbitals
i did it again i forgot my r two
orbitals have the same
n plus l then
the lower
n has lower
e okay this is called the n plus cell
rule but rules are made to be broken so
as we're gonna see
this is actually really only true um
maybe eighty percent of the time
but we're going to use it because it is
a good framework and it captures
um it gives us a way to start thinking
about
uh electron occupation and atoms and so
if you take these two points
this filling up in the ordering of how
you fill things then you can
you can draw this as a as a very simple
picture this is from
the textbook april right where what you
do is you follow the arrows
okay so you go this arrow i'm filling 1s
this arrow
then i go to 2s all right it's not going
anywhere so you go up there
and you keep following and this oh this
okay so like two okay uh
2s2p right so you'd fill 1s 2s then
2p right because the m plus l rules is
in effect
and then okay 3s n is 3
l is 0. so that's n plus l is 3. 2p
2p n is 2 l is 1 same value
but now i go to this one here and when
they have the same value the lower end
has lower energy
lower n filled first filled first
because the ordering is to go
from lowest energy up okay
all right so that's our rule which will
be broken
now how does this look well if we do
this
now we're going to get a little notation
here that's important
if we do this and we just do a few atoms
here so for hydrogen
all right so for hydrogen we'd have
that's the
the 1 s orbital and we're putting one
electron in it now the notation here is
something that we're going to use a lot
so let me explain this this is
this is n right this is
l that's the l in
what spectroscopic notation right
remember we talked about that monday
right
s p d okay um
and then this is the number of electrons
okay and so if we keep going with this
notation then and
then in the case of helium all right so
for helium
you would have one s two because i fill
a second electron into the 1s orbital
now
this is where paulie comes in right poly
said okay enough
you're done with that orbital because
i've got two electrons
they do have different quantum numbers
they've got the same men
right they've got the same l their m
sub ls are the same because there's no
range here for s
right remember m sub l for s can only be
you know zero but
they have different spins up and down
right and and so sometimes what is also
really useful and we'll go back and
forth between these pictures
is you go back to what we drew you know
with the bohr model
where we draw this in terms of energy
levels
right and so if you drew this in terms
of energy levels
this is what you'd see so you have like
energy
and remember in in the hydrogen atom
this is minus 13.6 electron volts
and so if you wanted to draw this in
this way you would say okay
there's one electron there and we'll
remember we said you can draw electron
spin
with arrows all right whereas here
if we tr if we drew this then we drawn
i'm not putting the energy there
we don't know it because bore 13.6 good
for hydrogen
right but here oh and by the way this
would be the 1s
orbital this would be the 1s orbital but
in this case
i've got 2 electrons one up one down
all right and now paulie
says you're done right and so if you go
to lithium
then you have one s two
two s 2s1 and so if you drew this in
terms of an energy diagram
you'd have you know the 1s and
we're putting that and then you have the
2s somewhere up higher
where we put one electron right those
are
and that's that's how you would see
these atoms in terms of the filling of
the electrons into their orbitals
right okay good
now uh okay let's keep going so what
we'll do is we'll do this here
so let's see so beryllium would be
1s2 2s2
and boron
would be 1s 2 two
s two two p one okay this is looking
good here right i'm
i'm really following aufbau now oh
i went that way then i went that way and
then i went up here
and i started on this arrow which is
just a way graphically of showing those
rules
okay good now um
uh we get to carbon
and now we have to think about this
right because
for carbon right for carbon i've got 1s2
2s2 2p2 that is correct
right but if i think about this in terms
of the energy
1s ah
two s all right well we know
from before right we know from before uh
like two two p where's two p there it is
it's got six electrons that it can take
because now
m sub l can vary from minus one
zero plus one right remember that
corresponded to
the three different orientations of the
p
orbital okay so but but that means that
i've got three
so i can fill this with two two and then
the question is what do i do
i i don't know what to do do i do this
is that right or no somebody says and
that person knows
that the answer is no because that
person knows hund
where's hun there he is would've been
more dramatic had he appeared
but there he is because hund came up
with another rule
which also is broken sometimes
not as much as auf powell but you know
uh
so so hun said look
uh when you have a case like this
electrons in the same in the same uh
p right so the same like orbital uh a
sub shell
okay it's not the same sub shell but
it's the same n
to p let's draw that it is the same sub
shell
i'm saying opposite things to p
to p shell sub shell
but there are different possibilities
and how you fill them according to hund
is you maximize what's called the
multiplicity which
means that you want the electrons to
come in
with the same spin in different orbitals
in different p
orbitals that's how you fill them
why well that has to do with
more quantum mechanics it has to do with
something called exchange energy that's
not part of what you need to know about
and i'm not going to teach it here
um but you know you can think about it
simply as
the electrons want to spread out because
they repel each other
in the same orbital right they want a
lot of things electrons
they want to be close to protons right
but they want to be kind of uh not close
to each other
they need their space right that's not a
lot of things it's two things
but that's what they want and this
allows them to maximize that and lower
their energy
and remember lowering your energy means
happiness for electrons
so this is the preferred way to fill
right
and that's what hund's rule tells us
now if you go to silicon
and you say well okay what does silicon
look like ah
all right i'm gonna put silicon no don't
do that
i'm gonna put silicon right underneath
carbon because i think it's an
interesting comparison
right so silicon is one okay 1s2
2s2 2p6
they're all filled right and then you go
to 3s
2 and you go to 3 p
two and this looks very different than
carbon but actually
you can abbreviate the notation and we
very often do in these
in these uh uh filling notation
and we do it this way we say well this
has a neon core
so you go to the nearest noble gas
not not with more electrons because
they're not there with less electrons
you go to the nearest noble gas and say
well okay
that's basically neon right this is
neon and so you can write the notation
is
is this this it's the same atom
just a slightly abbreviated way of
writing it where i would write okay
this is a neon core with 3s2
and 3p2 well you can write that with a
helium core
2s2 2p2 and what happens is
you wind up having a nice distinction
here because
these are core electrons remember we're
filling electrons here
that's electrons and these are called
valence electrons
and we'll be talking about valencia
you know valence chemistry for the whole
semester and what these valence
electrons
do right um
and and in fact these valence electrons
these ones on the outside
closest to the out very further furthest
away
these are the ones that have
all of the chemistry that we care about
in this class
chemistry it's so important
that i'm right i win all caps
i'm not shouting but i wet all caps
whereas the core electrons are kind of
mostly inert
they're mostly inert
chemically inert okay and so sometimes
it's very useful
um to write
the notation this way to see what do you
got in the valence
what's going on right what is this
valence
because then you start to see
similarities the valence for
you know for lithium and the valence for
sodium
look really similar right there's an
outer s electron this is the quantum
number
the principal quantum number is
different but the valence looks pretty
similar
one electron in an s orbital and that
gives us
that allows us to think intuitively
about similarities
between elements because if they have
the same valence and the valence
is responsible not same but similar
right similar shapes of orbitals
different principal numbers
but if that's similar then maybe the
chemistry those elements do is also
similar
all right so this is a helpful way to
think about it okay
i told you that rules are meant to be
broken especially when we're talking
about
n plus l and it happens all the time and
there's
there's two kind of main reasons or
important reasons and then there's a
whole bunch of other very complicated
ones
the two i want you to know about which
are exceptions to this aufbau filling
okay which are exceptions to that come
in the following situations that you get
stability
you get stability that means lower
energy for the whole system
the system lowers its energy and can be
more stable
when either an orbital is fully filled
uh there it is ns2 np6 nd 10
you know those are fully filled because
that's how many electrons you could put
in each one
or half filled exactly and so that's why
in chromium
if you predict with aufbau you would get
4s2 3d4 but actually you get 4s1
3d5 because you can half fill both of
those and that adds to the stability
right in copper the predicted one would
be 4s2 3d9 but actually what you see is
a fully filled d shell
which adds to stability and a half
filled s shell
so it's willing to make this trade-off
of a fully filled shell for half filled
that's not a big tradeoff to get the d
fully filled okay
now there's more complicated effects all
sorts of effects that also lead to
to violations of the n plus l rule i
really hesitate to call it a rule
given that you know there's a lot of
examples
where it's not about the half filling or
the fulfilling
it's about complicated interactions that
have to do sometimes
all the way with things like relativity
relativistic effects literally
of these electrons right which will not
be on any quiz or exam
right uh uh with also the complexities
that happen with orbital penetration as
you add more and more electrons and the
levels are kind of closer together
right there they're they're a lot harder
to see clearly separate energies
then in the first two three rows as you
go down in the periodic table
those levels are closer and closer
together so anomalies happen
but they're not really i'm not sure we
should call them anomalies because look
at these are all exceptions
to aufbau right so like i said i want
you to
know alph bob because it's a great way
to start but i also want you to know
that sometimes things switch around
because of the effects that we've been
talking about
i don't expect you to memorize all the
exceptions
to outfelt okay but i do want you to
know about these two key
uh key factors which are half filling
and fully filling leading to enhanced
stability
all right good okay so we got valence
we got filling now um
right away right away all right these
so so by the way
configurations are in here
it's a beautiful thing when i when i
look at this i now can look at this line
in here
that shows that shows using this
notation
the filling of electrons for every
single atom every single atom
and it's a beautiful thing because it
tells us
so much about the periodic table it
tells us so much about
why the periodic table is what it is it
was arranged
right it was arranged um because of
you know things like the combination
remember mendeleev
mass and properties right
but now we see why we see why
it's it's incredible because it's it
goes back to counting
it literally goes back to the quantum
mechanical derivations of orbitals
and the principles of filling them and
then the filling them themselves
and you see you know why do the
lanthanides and actinides
why do those things run for 14
because that's how many electrons go
into the f
orbitals right that's how many electrons
go into 4f and 5f
that's why these are 14. why are these
two columns
here why are those why do those have
similar properties as you go down
right like i mentioned lithium and
sodium right well
because of what we just said you're
increasing the principal quantum number
but the valence chemistry
is very similar they're all s
right and we even call them sometimes
these blocks
by the valence chemistry that's getting
filled right so those
those first two columns are the s block
here over here they're the p block it's
not that these don't have p
electrons in them it's that these are
the electrons that are getting added
all right in in this part in this region
whereas here
you've got d electrons and now we know
exactly why this is 10.
i mean we know even more than this
because aufbau says why is this here
and not here right because of the
ordering of the filling of the energies
of the filling
these three d's come after 4s
that's why they're here right that's why
they belong here
we now know so much more we have so much
more
insight into the ordering of the
periodic table
because of electron filling and we'll be
making those connections
we'll be making those connections a lot
right but i just wanted to kind of
show you the power
of seeing things in terms of filling the
one connection i'll tell you about today
has to do with diameter
okay so we'll be making connections all
throughout the class
between electron filling and properties
right but let's start with a simple one
how big is an atom
well now you can understand some things
right so for example
if i plot here or if avril plots it and
i take that from april
and show it to you the probability
remember that we plotted this before for
one
s two s two now what what they plot
here is okay the one s orbital for
helium
that's got two electrons in it there it
is right there the 1s and then the 2s
and 2p
combined right everything is sort of
thrown together here they're not
separated
separated for neon and then argon so
these are the these are the first three
noble gases helium
neon argon okay um and
and a couple things one thing you can
see is
that the s electrons
in helium are furthest out right and
then the neon ones are closer in
and look at that the argon ones are even
closer why
how's that why are the 1s electrons
getting closer in as i add more
electrons
right well it has to do with what we
talked about monday
those 1s electrons are not screened so
what they see as you go from helium to
neon to argon is just more and more
positive charge
right in fact i've got the numbers here
you know if you look
at the 1s electron energy
all right remember for hydrogen
13.6 now remember i didn't write a value
there but there's two protons
so that that 1s electron for helium
so if we take 1s electron
energy oh so much abbreviation
right for helium it's 24.5 ev that's how
much it would take
right so we can put minus if you want to
compare with this
right this minus 13.6 that's also how
much it would take to ionize
that 1s electron that's where it sits
right but if you look at
at neon neon is minus 800 869.5
ev oh and argon
is minus 3206 ev
that is a lot of energy that is a lot
more energy that is
much much happier if energy if lower
energy is happiness
those 1s electrons are super happy and
they get closer
to all that positive charge but but you
can also understand why
like neon is larger than helium
and argon even though these energies of
the 1s are closer and closer
these are still going to be larger
because
as you go down in a column
you go you add a whole shell right
so i can't so right so remember here's
my plus charge
here's my minus charge i i can't this is
1s
now i can't add anything in here i got
to add
stuff out here and go out remember those
those uh those principal quantum numbers
one to two
right just we don't need the s here just
one to two to three
they're going to push you further and
further out all right we talked about
that monday
so now the next electrons that come in
in neon's case 2s and 2p or in
in argon's case 3s and 3b those are
going to come much further out that's
why
when you look at size which is what's
shown here
you see this trend right so you see this
trend that
as you go down a column here they are
here they are
so this is the size in the periodic
table and these are calculated
these are calculated why are they
calculating because you can see this
would be pretty hard to measure
right these are hard to measure unless
the atoms are in
like a solid and they're bonded together
right so measured atomic radii are often
taking say half of a bond length but we
can also calculate them
and that's why this is these are
calculated atomic radii so these have no
bonding they're just
isolated atoms and they're calculated
and there's helium neon
and argon okay fine so we just
understood that
and we understood this arrow that the
radii get larger as you go down the
periodic table
but what about going across why
i'm adding stuff to the atom i'm
filling lithium here i'm
adding an electron and going from
lithium
there to beryllium how can it get
smaller
right how can it get smaller right so so
that has to do
what did i do i'm
okay i'm going over here right so that
has to do with the fact
with the same things that we've been
talking about right it has to do with
the fact that as i go from lithium
so okay let's do this if i have hydrogen
and i go to lithium you know that it's
going to be larger
for the reasons i just said
but if i go from lithium over to
beryllium
it gets smaller right
and the reason is because of exactly
this if i
if i go from hydrogen to lithium
i add uh uh protons but i shield those
protons with electrons
okay but if i am at lithium let's see
lithium is here so i've got one
two three and i've got an electron here
right i've got two electrons in the 1s
orbital
and then i've got two like i've got one
electron in the 2s orbital
okay so that's lithium but now i go to
beryllium
and and if i'm beryllium
i've got four okay
and so now i've got those 2s electrons
here
but see in the ch and i'm sorry 1s
but in the 2s orbital i can put a second
electron
right and so what happens is those two
electrons in the 2s
orbital they don't really screen each
other
they are screened by the 1s orbital
so if i now so because i went
from even though i added an electron i
also
have a lot more charge here right and
because these two
don't screen each other but these two do
right these are going to be closer in
because they're more attractive they're
only screened by these two electrons
right so so the the additional positive
charge
wins if i go down in quantum number
then i get a whole shell filled to
screen
but here i'm just adding another
electron to the same orbital to the 2s
orbital but i've got a whole other
proton and the shielding
the screening is the same that's why
beryllium is smaller than lithium even
though you've added an electron and it's
why
the trend goes like this increasing that
way decreasing that way
right now i like i like
dancing and so i like this dancing
analogy
because i love thinking about atoms as
dancing
i told you about the disco and the
periodic table but you can take that all
the way to the atom
so um you know you can imagine that
you're an electron
and you see a proton so we're going to
try this out okay so
dance pairs are happy dancers are happy
if they have more people to dance with
right uh and so if i'm hydrogen and i'm
an electron and i see a protein
protons can only dance with electrons
and then i say okay let's dance and you
kind of start grouping
you know a little bit and then okay but
now i'm i'm uh
going to go to helium so there's another
dancer in the middle
and someone comes along and says oh okay
that's cool right
i can now either one of us can dance
with either one of those
all right so i've got two different
people i'm happier closer in
we can get close because there's choices
for who you can dance with
right so so that that but so that's why
you get
helium much smaller than hydrogen
right more people to dance with now
you're lithium and you come along
and i'm a lithium electron here and i'm
like i want to dance with somebody
who's there and there's only one person
because these two people are totally
occupied
i only have one possibility for people
to dance with
if i'm lithium if i'm this lithium
electron
right yeah but now i come in and i'm i'm
beryllium and these two electrons and
they're both like
well okay you guys are blocking whatever
that's not cool
but there's four people in the middle so
there's there's always two free people
right that we can dance with that wasn't
like a move i don't know what that was
but i'm like i can dance with you or i
could dance with you
and and more dancing choices
happier happier lower energy
so uh so that's how i like to see atoms
anyway okay now okay
so that's one example of filling and
screening
and dancing where
this kind of picture of the atoms this
electron filling of the orbitals
explains
what we see okay now
we talked about ionization and we talked
about how
sometimes those outer electrons can be
lost
right or sometimes maybe an atom would
gain an outer electron
if an electron is lost from an atom
that's called an ion right and so
a charged
charged atom
is an ion and
a cation is a positive charge
positive charge whole abbreviations
right and so here's sodium and it's got
those all those dancers in there
and and it has lost an electron there it
is
it's going to lose remember we talked
about the first ionization potential
all right we talked about that last week
it's going to lose that
lowest sorry highest energy electron the
least bound
electron the one that's all the way out
there and and so if it does it's it's n
a plus
right okay goes in tight
now you can also this is from april you
can also lose
more than that right magnesium might
lose two electrons
so the gray part here is the ion and the
blue part is
is the original neutral atom right
and you can see that if if if sodium
loses one electron and magnesium loses
two
those actually have the same number of
electrons or different atoms
those are called isoelectronic right
well you can also gain electrons and so
if you let's write that down so
you know if you gain electrons does
anybody know what those are called
anion okay negative charge
would be an anion
okay and i can ask questions you see
like if i lose an electron it makes
sense that i got smaller this is the
radius
and if i gain it makes sense that i got
bigger and i can mix it up
right so i could ask you a question like
what's the ordering what's the ordering
of these these atoms right i could say
well if i had
mg two plus and
c a two plus and c
a what's the ordering of their size
you now know how to answer questions
like this right so if i lose electrons
i'm going to get smaller if i gain
electrons to get bigger but i also know
that for example you know
c a 2 plus is smaller than c
a and c a is bigger
than mg right and so ca2 plus
is going to be bigger than mg2 plus
all right that makes a lot of sense done
you can order them now all right so ca
must be bigger than ca2 plus
and that must be bigger than mg2 plus so
we can think about now
adding in ions to the mix and we're
doing this for a reason
right we're doing this for a reason um
but but before because you see some
atoms really don't mind doing this
they really don't sodium's one of them
all right they don't mind losing atoms
i mean yeah the electron is there but
it's kind of there it's sort of like
you know i could be here i could be
there
i'm good whereas those 1s electrons you
know
the 1s electrons are argon are like you
just try to take me out
right no way but
but we will we will ionize those
next week but for now right we're taking
these outer ones out that may not be
may not be strongly balanced or they're
they're happy losing
or gaining and how do you know how do
you know
if you have uh ions how do you know
you know whether you have them well
here's the deal you now
know a way to tell because in this
goodie bag which i'll talk about in a
few minutes
you actually have the most accurate
measuring device
ever made you have a scale
that's not no it's it's in here
somewhere
you have a conductivity meter somewhere
in here
which i cannot find and the conductivity
meter
is exactly that there it is huh look at
this
this is incredible so you can put this
into a solution
and it it literally just measured it's
got two electrodes that go in there and
it measures
whether there's any conduction and you
can you can see well if i've got charged
species in the solution
ions then this will tell you because
they'll help conduct electricity
so you now have a way of knowing when
you have ions or not
okay so that's good but you see the
thing is
something very important happens when
atoms come
together when atoms don't measure
anything yet
but take it to lunch take it to lunch
you don't know people talk about
electrolytes they talk a big game
all right now
the thing is when atoms react
when ah this sounds like the beginning
of a novel
when atoms react right
sometimes they will gain or lose
when atoms react they may want to gain
or lose the amount of electrons
to get them
to the closest noble gas okay
closest noble gas
now that that's really important we just
talked about how you use the noble gas
notation to
just erase it i did right
uh because that could be chemically
inert but so
and and we can only go down when we do
the notation but now we can go up
because i could add electrons to get to
the nearest noble gas right in terms of
reacting and look at this if sodium is
an atom
that doesn't mind losing electrons and
chlorine is an atom that really wants to
gain electrons
and they come together and they come
together
then you can form a bond oh
oh boy here we are
i guarantee you i told you on monday we
would get here
i said it's our three week anniversary
and i think we're going to bond
first bond
first bond and it's ionic
it's ionic
because this is the bond of
an electrostatic electrostatic
attraction
this is the bond of electrostatic
attraction
between two oppositely charged atoms
right so between
two oppositely charged
charged
atoms and so if i've got a positive and
a negative
they're going to be attracted how are
they going to be attracted well actually
that's an attraction that we don't know
all about okay there it is hold up we
just made our first bond
let's talk about it what do i want to
say i want to talk about that attraction
because that's actually attraction that
we know very well it's a coulomb
attraction
right and so the way this works is if
i'm an atom with positive charge
and i'm an atom with negative charge
right
so let's take that same example and this
is the energy
and this is say zero and this is the
distance between the two atoms
and now if i'm out here then
maybe the distance between sodium and
chlorine
is very far but you see there's a
coulomb attraction
and so the attraction is coulomb
which is going to be minus a constant
times the charges
on those ions over
the distance between them right
so that if i draw that attraction this
is the charges on ions
charges
on ions and if i draw that the coulomb
attraction looks like this
that's it right that's one over r and
but see the thing is if they get too
close
then those core you know then things
start to repel
it's like hold on i'm not gonna
go any further because i don't like
having
the same charges getting too close
right i don't like that your electrons
are getting too close to my electrons
and don't make me go nuclear and so
and so what you get is you get something
like this
right and this would be
the potential energy of those two ions
they can't get super duper close but
when they're far away
they're kind of free and then as they
get a little closer they start feeling
that attraction that coulomb attraction
and this energy here this energy
has a name it's called the lattice
energy
because
for the solid right so if i if i make a
solid
out of these out of these types of of
ions
and now i break it all up and i go all
the way out to just
just lone ion so i go from the isolated
ions
to a solid of these ionic bonds
then i gain this energy and it takes
that energy to break them back up
that's called the lattice energy and you
can see right away there's some really
kind of interesting observations you can
make related
to this simple relationship of a coulomb
attraction for an
an ionic bond all right so here's two
ionic solids
there's uh sodium fluoride there's
magnesium oxide there's
n a plus and f minus okay
and notice the coulomb energy here and
notice the differences in the lattice
energies this is like
four times that that is exactly
what you get from this because in this
case q1 and q2 are both
one right one and negative one and here
q1 and q2 are both
two and negative two so so it's
it should be four times and that's in
fact you can measure how much energy
does it take to break this thing up
four times as much that's the lattice
energy so we know something about this
and you can see
trends right so these are now the radii
we just talked about these
right radii for ions ions
and this is the lattice energy and you
can see that if on the smallest one
and the smallest one there i have the
highest lattice energy and that's the
one over r part
so you got the charge and how close they
can get
and you now know from just from the
trends we just talked about
right the the radii trends we just
talked about you know
how you might compare how much one ionic
solid is bonded compared to another
right because you can talk about how
much charge it might
lose or gain it likes to get closer to
the near close to the nearest
noble gas and you can also think about
their size or relative sizes so like
the largest one with the largest one has
a larger r and so
weaker lattice energy right
and boy is this uh important it changes
all sorts of things about the properties
of these solids and i that's why
we developed a goodie bag to help you
explore that
and so you have different solids they're
not all ionic
because you're talking about another
kind of solid next week right but you've
got some ionic solids and look
like you know so a lot of them dissolve
but if the lattice energy is so high
maybe it doesn't dissolve or maybe it's
harder to dissolve how do you know well
you could see it if you stir it
right but you also may be able to
measure are there ions in solution
if there are ions in solution then it it
could be a dissolved
ionic solid that you've made right
and so oh hardness most scale you can
look that up
did something scratch something else
right uh that's that's what that's
related to
melting point right the properties
depend on
this ionic bond okay now
uh okay so there's the goodie bag and
then i'll do my why this matters in the
last couple of minutes of class
right so there's the goodie bag oh
you've got a conductivity meter you've
got a scale
you've got a scale
i used to give that scale out with white
powder right before thanksgiving
for a different goodie bag and it was a
really bad idea
but now now
it was night it was citric acid lime
juice right but uh
but people traveled like that um and so
we've learned
we've learned and so we give it to you
now but please keep it
it's the world's most accurate scale why
does this matter because
look you're going to need the scale
again so please keep it
um here you go here's another chart of
ionic bonds
these are lattice energies okay these
are lattice energies
right oh kilojoules per mole it's just
per mole of stuff right don't get
confused by that
joules electron volts energies per mole
is per mole of atoms right okay that's
okay so
you could isolate it down to one bond or
a mole of bonds
right 15 000
for alumina look at that that's why
alumina is in your toothpaste
aluminum oxide is in your toothpaste
it's it's in your pans
it's in sandpaper it is a very hard
material
it is a very hard material why because
of this
literally those cues are really high
right why does this matter well i'm
going to give you an example in
hemodialysis
hemodialysis is something that people
have to go into a hospital people who
have
do not in their kidneys don't clean
their blood
efficiently or enough have to have it
cleaned by a machine
and 650 000 patients suffer from this
and
go to a hospital for literally four
hours
three times a week yeah it devastates
their their weekly schedule
um and if you could make this portable
you would change lives in a really big
way
one of the big and there are there are
people out there trying to do this
this is an example of a design for a
portable hemodialysis machine
one of the single biggest drawbacks in
making it portable
is making a filter because you're
filtering blood you're filtering toxins
out of the blood
there's something that the body can't do
so you need to do it for them
right but the filters get mucked up and
gunked up and they're
not strong enough and they can't be
cleaned and look at this one
here's a filter made out of alumina
right
and these things are what's needed we
need
super strong super resilient new filters
that can filter things like blood and
toxins out of the blood so very very
tiny sizes that we can make over large
areas and uniformly
this is the kind of starting material
that we need to make new filters
and it all comes back down why would
that be a good one if we can overcome
its brittleness
because of the cues because of the atom
sizes because of everything
that we talked about today so have a
great long weekend
and see you guys next week
you